is there a case to be made that brothers
karamazov is the greatest book ever
written
yeah there's a case to be made for that
i don't know is it better than crime and
punishment
yes yeah you think so why do you i'm not
arguing with it why do you think that uh
well this is every every book is a
person some of my best friends are
inside that book yeah it's an amazing
book and there's no doubt about it uh i
think it's
some
books are
defined by your personal relationship
with them and that one was definitive
and i almost graduated to that one
because for the longest time
the idiot was my favorite book
uh of all
because i identified with the ideas
represented by prince michigan i also
identified oh that's interesting to
prince michigan as a as a human being
holy fool the fool because the world
kind of
my whole life
still kind of sees me saw me in my
perception my
narrow perception is kind of
the fool
and
i
different from the interpretation that a
lot of people take of this book
i see him as a kind of hero to be oh
definitely to be a naive
uh quote-unquote fool but really just a
naive optimist
and naive in the best possible way i i
do believe that
childlike yeah childlike is a butter so
naive is usually seen as that's childish
naive yeah but child like
that's why no one enters the kingdom of
heaven unless they become like a child
that's prince mishkin dostoevsky knew
that
so that's why you like the idiot that's
so interesting see i think i like crime
and punishment because you while you
identified with michigan i think i
identified more with raskolnikov because
i was tempted by a luciferian intellect
you know in in in the manner that
in a in a manner very similar to the
manner he was tempted but i mean i think
i think you can make a case that the
brothers chromosome is
dostoevsky's crowning achievement
wow and that's something man all right
he ruined literature for me
because everything else just felt
insipid afterwards not everything
not everything
i i found some books that
in my experience
hit that pinnacle um the master in
margarita
that's a deadly book i've read that i
think four times and i still there's
still it's unbelievably deep
uh there's a nikos kazansicus a greek
writer
some of his books are
his writing is amazing as well did you
ever connect with the literary like
existentialist camus
uh or or people like carmen hesse or um
or even kafka
did you ever connect with those to the
same degree yeah to the same enough to
be an influence
you know you have to be deaf in some
fundamental sense not to encounter a
great dead friend and fail to learn
no and and i mean i tried to separate
the wheat from the chaff when i read
you know and i read all the great
clinicians all of them perhaps not
those who are foremost in the pantheon
and i tried to pull out what i could and
that was a lot i learned a lot from
freud i learned a lot from rogers and i
learned a lot from well from dostoevsky
and nietzsche i'm going to do a course
on dostoevsky and nietzsche for this
peterson academy this is coming up in
january oh that'll be
damn i'm really looking forward to it
you're weaving
i mean i hadn't thought about doing them
together oh that'd be fun that's a good
idea well the other good idea
uh there's a you feel that idea
you often weave them together really
masterfully because there is a
there is
religious
in the broad sense of that word themes
throughout the writing of both yeah
there is uncanny parallelisms in their
writing and their lives
so
um
and dostoevsky's deeper than nietzsche
but that's because he was a
writer of fiction nietzsche is almost a
character in a dusty yes he is
definitely that he is definitely that
yes
and apparently nietzsche knew more about
dostoevsky than people had thought
there's been some recent scholarship on
that grounds dostoevsky didn't know
anything about nietzsche as far as i
know i could be wrong about that but
the thing that dostoevsky had over
nietzsche is nietzsche had to make
things propositional in some real sense
because he was a philosopher and
it's hard to propositionalize things
that are outside your can but you can
characterize them and so
in the brothers karamazov ivan is a more
developed character than alyosha
in in in the explicit sense he can make
better arguments
but elosha
wins like michigan because he's the
better man and dostoevsky can show that
in the actions rather
he can't render it entirely
propositional but that's probably
because what's good can't be rendered
entirely propositional
and so dostoevsky had that edge over
nietzsche i said well ivan is this
brilliant rationalist atheist
materialist and puts forward an argument
on that front that's still unparalleled
as far as i'm concerned
and overwhelms eliot who cannot respond
but eliot is still the better man
so which is very interesting you know
that what you know the funny thing about
those two characters is
you jordan peterson seem to be somebody
that at least
embodies both
because you are one of the intellectuals
of our time
rigorous in thought but also
are able to have that kind of
what would you describe if you if you
remove the religiosity of aryosha
there's a
what's a good word love towards the
world spirit of encouragement
yes
well it's it's you know one of the
things i did
learn perhaps from looking into the
abyss to the degree that i have
had to
or was willing to
was that at some level you have to make
a fundamental statement of faith
when god creates the world after each
day he says
he saw that it was good
you think well is it good it's like well
there's a tough question you know do you
want to bring a child into a world such
as this which is a fundamental question
of whether or not it's good
it's an act of faith to declare that
it's good
because the evidence is ambivalent
and so then you think okay well
am i going to act as if it's good
and what would happen if i did
and maybe the answer to that is
i think this is the answer
the more you act
out the proposition that it's good
the better it gets
and so that's dostoyevsky said this is
something else
every man is not only responsible for
everything he does but for everything
everyone else does
it's like
what is that profound or are you just
insane
then you think
is what you receive back proportionate
to what you deliver
and the answer to that might be yes
that's a terrifying idea man
and it certainly you can see that it's
true in some sense because people
certainly
respond to you
in kind with how you treat them that's
certainly the case i mean it's it's
terrifying and it's exciting yeah right
that's an adventure isn't it you uh
uh yeah
you create the world
by
the way you live it
the the world you experience is is
defined by the way you live that world
that's really that's really interesting
and then taken as a collective we create
the world together in that way
you